IN OUR OUT OF THIS WORLD LEAD
TODAY, THE U.S. GOVERNMENT KNOWS
SOMETHING UNEXPLAINED IS OUT
THERE AND NEXT MONTH WE MAY GET
ANSWERS.
THE PENTAGON HAS UNTIL LATE JUNE
TO TELL CONGRESS IN AN
UNCLASSIFIED REPORT WHAT IT
KNOWS ABOUT UNIDENTIFIED FLYING
OBJECTS.
NOW, TO BE CLEAR, THE GOVERNMENT
IS STILL BEING SECRETIVE ABOUT
WHAT THE HECK MAY BE OUT THERE,
BUT IT HAS BEEN MORE FORTHCOMING
IN YEARS RECENT YEARS IN THAT IT
IS INVESTIGATING SIGHTINGS
INCLUDING PHOTOS AND VIDEO TAKEN
BY NAVAL PERSONNEL.
YOU COULD SEE A NAVY PILOT BLOWN
AWAY AND BIZARRE WHEN HIS
INFRARED CAMERA CAPTURED AN
OBJECT IN THE ATLANTIC OCEAN IN
2015.
>> MY GOSH -- IT'S GOING AGAINST
THE WINDS.
THE WIND IS 120 KNOTS TO THE
WEST.
>> IT'S ROTATING.
>> LET'S BRING LUIS ALIZONDO.
HE RAN THE SIGHTINGS OF UAP OR
WHAT WE CALL UNIDENTIFIED FLYING
OBJECTS AND LUIS, THE PENTAGON
NOW CALLS THE DEPARTMENT YOU LED
THE UAP TASK FORCE AND IT'S
COLLECTING DATA ON THESE
MYSTERIOUS SIGHTINGS.
COULD THESE OBJECTS BE SPY CRAFT
FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WILL,ELL, JAKE, THANKS FOR HG
ME.
THAT'S THE BIG QUESTION.
WHAT ARE THESE THINGS?
WE DON'T KNOW.
ANY SCENARIO WE GO DOWN IS NOT A
GOOD SCENARIO, AND ON THE ONE
HAND IT COULD BE ADVERSARIAL
TECHNOLOGY FLYING IN U.S.
AIRSPACE AND ON THE OPPOSITE END
OF THE SPECTRUM YOU HAVE
SOMETHING THAT'S COMPLETELY AND
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT THAN ANYTHING
WE ARE AWARE OF IN ANYBODY'S
INVENTORY AND EITHER WAY, THESE
THINGS ARE BEING WITNESSED BY
SOME OF OUR BEST FIGHTER PILOTS
AND THEY'RE BEING PICKED UP ON
ELECTRO-OPTICAL DEVICES, AND
IT'S FURTHERMORE BEING
SUBSTANTIATED BY RADAR DATA.
WE KNOW THEY'RE REAL, WHATEVER
IT IS.
>> RETIRED NAVY PILOT HAD A WILD
DESCRIPTION AFTER WHAT HE SAW IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN 2004.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE TOLD "60
MINUTES."
>> TO THE SOUTH AND IT TURNS
ABRUPTLY AND STARTS MIRRORING ME
SO AS I START COMING DOWN IT
STARTS COMING UP.
>> IT'S MIMICKING YOUR MOVES.
>> I GO LIKE THIS AND IT'S
CLIMBING STILL AND IT GETS RIGHT
IN FRONT OF ME AND IT JUST
DISAPPEARS.
>> DISAPPEARS.
>> LIKE, GONE.
>> TO BE CLEAR, HE'S REFERRING
TO THIS GIANT OBJECT AS A TIC
TAC.
IT WAS SHAPED LIKE ONE.
THREE OTHER CREW MEMBERS SAW THE
SAME THING.
ARE THESE OBJECTS A NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERN GIVEN THE FACT
THAT RESPECTED, CREDIBLE
MILITARY PERSONNEL ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THESE SIGHTINGS?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, LET ME ASK YOU THE SAME
QUESTION.
I MEAN, IF THIS WAS FLYING OVER
CONTROLLED U.S. AIRSPACE, SAY
WASHINGTON D.C. OVER THE WHITE
HOUSE WOULD THIS BE AN ISSUE?
THE ANSWER IS CERTAINLY, YES,
AND THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT
THESE THINGS DON'T HAVE
TRADITIONAL, LET'S SAY,
TECHNOLOGY SOSS YATED WITH
AIRCRAFT.
THEY DON'T HAVE WINGS.
THEY DON'T HAVE COCKPITS AND NO
OBVIOUS SIGNS OF PROPULSION AND
YET SOMEHOW THEY'RE ABLE TO
OUTPERFORM ANYTHING WE HAVE IN
OUR CURRENT INVENTORY.
>> THE PENTAGON MUST SUBMIT ITS
DETAILED REPORT BY LATE JUNE TO
THE SENATE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS THE REPORT
ON THESE SIGHTINGS.
TOP-SECRET MATERIAL WILL BE
INCLUDED IN A CLASSIFIED
VERSION.
DO YOU EXPECT TO SEE REAL
ANSWERS IN THIS REPORT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> LOOK, HONESTLY, I DON'T THINK
SO, JAKE.
IT TAKES 180 DAYS TO DO A
REPORT.
IT TAKES LONGER TO REMODEL A
KITCHEN IN YOUR HOUSE SOMETIMES.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
BEGINNING.
I THINK CONGRESS DESERVES A COM
PRO HENCIVE REPORT AND SO DO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND I JUST DON'T
THINK 180 DAYS IS GOING TO BE
SUFFICIENT.
I THINK CONGRESS IS AWARE OF
THAT.
SO MY HOPE IS THAT THIS WILL BE
AN INTERIM REPORT WITH A MUCH
MORE COMPREHENSIVE REPORT TO
FOLLOW.
>> COMMENT IN THE MINUTE WE HAVE
LEFT ABOUT THE WEIRD AND
CONTRADICTORY STATEMENTS THE
PENTAGON HAS GIVEN OVER THE
DECADES ABOUT THIS.
FOR DECADES THE GOVERNMENT
DENIED AREA 51 AND THEY BRUSHED
OFF THESE MYSTERIOUS KINDS OF
SIGHTINGS AND THEY'RE
ACKNOWLEDGING IT AND THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN HONEST ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE LOOKING
AT UNEXPLAINED PHENOMENON.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> I THINK THE PENTAGON ARE
TRYING TO WRAP THEIR HEAD AROUND
THIS TOPIC AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR DECADES
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
BECOMING WISE TO THE FACT AND SO
HAS THE GOVERNMENT.
THE QUESTION IS NOW THAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS BACKED ITSELF
INTO THE CORNER, PARTICULARLY
ELEMENTS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE IT HAS TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO GET OUT OF THAT CORNER
AND IT'S TRICKY.
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU HAVE THIS
FLIP-FLOPPING BACK AND FORTH AND
FINALLY THIS BEGRUDGING
ACCEPTANCE THAT, YES, THIS IS
REAL.
THE TOPIC IS REAL AND WE'VE BEEN
DEAL